I reject nation greg alba here tara
erickson I did it right that time yeah
you did hi dear Tara yeah you ever been
on a date at a French restaurant no no
I've done my dates are over that good
take me out French improv is yes and
have French food I say oh I love French
food and give me a crosshatch cross set
or fresh wine that's good that's good
hey key and Peele you ever heard of
these guys sure have Jordan Peele who
directed a movie get out that's the one
key who's in the the new predator movie
if your mom's vagina were a video game
and be rated E for Everyone they
uploaded this video got a lot of
requests to check it out I have not seen
this sketch French restaurant me neither
I'm excited need a headphone I need to
put my headphones you know tara has
sketches on her youtube channel I do see
how we said we link that reason a
springer on today
isn't that cool isn't that cool this
place is so nice this is supposed to be
one of the best French places in town I
did not realize that you were so
cultured you're sweet my French is
pretty good so I can order for both of
us
also welcome to shade ellenmilton banter
I am your waiter for this evening my
name is jean-luc de la pierre I will not
but you make initial moles ozone will be
on any questions about anything at all
I'm more than happy to assist you
[Music]
merci beaucoup ABA well our first
special tonight is our Poisson du jour
is a Loup de mer bleue of a song served
with a premium Val de cochon de promote
that is served on a pair the gentle
filly sapa and officer in occlusion and
souffle petite a Fiat or DuPont Kanye
you know our soup today and served with
melted be sold to chef back with you
today from the belly and visitor it is
[Music]
what do you think I'm gonna defer to him
on this one
because he knows the stuff way better
than I do yeah well we'll have the song
[Laughter]
it's been nice knowing you have a lovely
dinner remember those days at the key &
peele days oh god it's so good memories
coming back
I used to binge watch these guys all the
time because I didn't have Comedy
Central never had Comedy Central
so I only access to watching key and
Peele was on YouTube I was like
surprised to see this up here just
watching Eric spew I want to go back to
just binge eat them have you ever seen a
[ __ ] on the chain wax sketch that is so
like I remember like hats and they're
like yeah but this one oh my goodness is
so good the payoff at the end is just so
great it makes me want them to come back
because they've kind of been doing their
own thing lately Jordan peels very busy
winning Oscars and he's been like
working on other shows and movies now
and it's cool that they're doing their
own thing going their separate ways and
maybe like in two years it would be cool
as their their footing is really
established without being is so
associated together they had to come
back and be like oh the reunited
sometimes your sketches can escalate
into craziness but I also love it when
their sketches are rather simple here's
a simple sketch yeah yeah very simple
just a guy who poses like he knows
French really well but doesn't and he's
just embarrassed by the end it's a
simple sketch it's well written and well
acted and just simple edit really well
done and I missed these guys a lot oh
good I just want to go to a French
restaurant and be like I feel like a
French is the easiest one to [ __ ]
your way through to make a full-size
whole even your French gibberish sounds
sexy because you have a woman's voice my
French voice to me though sounds abusive
yeah trying to raise it up oh I want to
raise it up a little bit I don't know
where my face does that my face to do
that it's like a lot better than
Americans French in person everybody
loves it this is improv show with terror
and wreck yeah we do a lot of Pippi not
puke yeah
Oh Frankie Frank and then silent face
dancing and telling you to shut up
laugh at the jokes in the crowd [ __ ]
nobody wants to hear nobody want to hear
them oh shut up
yeah I thought about the crowd no zip I
understand if it is zipper we throw away
the part of it work so he can't unzip it
so then that way he just there
aesthetically which is fine he can wave
and make facial expressions keeps
escalating he can't talk which would
make better for all of us honestly right
then I do all the talking they're like
thank God you know get rid of that dial
tone
and I'm like Don I know it might close
this out
sure ring my clothes out yeah oh here
I'll do curtains and then I'll tell him
curtains make sure that you subscribe to
him and his stuff the real rejects will
do curtains again subscribe also to be
Tara Ericsson t-ara Eri su casa when we
were both on patreon I see him here
doing this stuff and I was like I'm not
gonna look at him cuz I might laugh or I
might not know what to say and then I
realized that he's just trying not to
talk because I said earlier that it
would be a breeze if he didn't I feel a
lot more comfortable now so hey
subscribe to the rail rejects also
subscribe to Tara Ericsson I do lost
stuff on YouTube and patreon and you
know face dancing you know just cool
things more than what he's doing you
know I mean he's just who knows
you know I mean told you not to be so
abusive anymore don't worry idea we
found I don't know it's just a thing it
comes over me and then I just feel I
feel like I just feel like I need to be
mean to you you know what I mean
otherwise like people are always just
they're always nice to you there was
nice nice nice and smiling and it's like
no maybe maybe somebody just needs to be
not so nice to you once in a while we're
not filming right now so I just wanted
to tell you that your real pain in the
ass I hope your career suffers it
doesn't it won't it'll only get better
okay cuz if your if your real pain in
the ass it also means most of time
talented too you know I'm not sure boy
oh boy she a pain but she's got some
talent on her you know what I mean [ __ ]
my apartment not leavin definitely
staying